the universe is magnificent and vast
hundreds of billions of galaxies
trillions of stars and even more planets
if even the tiniest fraction are
habitable then the universe should be
teeming with life and yet we see nothing
only vast emptiness
where is everyone else
[Music]
the answer to this riddle could be as
exciting as it is creepy
we are early born before almost all
other life but very soon this may change
not only might aliens appear they could
quickly surround us an irreversible
competition for the universe might be
about to begin
[Music]
while this video is based on scientific
papers we're presenting interesting
ideas based on little data and lots of
extrapolation so take them with a grain
of salt
okay we need to look at three essential
questions to understand the galactic
competition
one how fast can bacteria build
spaceships to become a star-faring
civilization Life as we know it needs to
master a number of very hard steps it
starts with dead stuff turning into the
building blocks of life
then it needs to organize into
self-contained cells those cells have to
learn to work together to form
multicellular organisms
this keeps going until complex creatures
with big brains learn to use tools and
language the civilization has to be
formed from cultures that value progress
and technological development and then
they need to actually venture out beyond
their home planet
on Earth life appeared basically as soon
as the oceans fought but then it took
two billion years to make the step from
single cells to multicellular organisms
and 2 billion more for us to appear
culture civilization and space travel
developed super quickly though do things
always take that long or was this
actually exceptionally fast also passing
One Step does not mean the next one is
guaranteed
multicellularity evolved over 25 times
independently on Earth but there's only
one species that builds spaceships
we don't know how many steps life needs
to pass and how long they take to give
rise to a technological civilization but
there are probably many and it's likely
that on trillions of planets life has
been trying for billions of years
since we don't see any other
technological civilizations out there it
might well be that we are a rare
exception we might be among the first or
even the first technological
civilization in the Milky Way
but this is just one piece of the puzzle
on top of that we may have just hit the
perfect time window why does Humanity
exist now
the universe is already 13.8 billion
years old but it's unlikely that many
other technological civilizations had a
chance to appear before us
because in the earlier universe life
would have had a pretty hard time to
emerge let alone Thrive because it was
such a hostile environment
early Stars constantly blew up galaxies
crashed into each other and supermassive
black holes vomited massive amounts of
radiation enough to sterilize galaxies
over and over again
our son was born right at the end of
this Cosmic death show the universe has
never been more welcoming to life than
it is now
so Humanity has arrived at a very
convenient spot in time maybe the
earliest reasonably possible for life to
thrive
what about the future the sun burns
brighter than 90 percent of the stars in
our galaxy and will keep getting
brighter in about a billion years it
will boil all of Earth's oceans and then
become a giant that swallows it whole
so in the galactic context the sun is
very short-lived most stars are red
dwarfs that can sustain habitable
planets for tens of trillions of years
life on these planets has an incredibly
long time window to appear and pass the
heart steps
even knowing nothing about how rare or
common life is this makes it way more
likely for technological civilizations
to appear sometime in the future than in
the past
because if civilizations appear at
random in the Milky Way within a Time
window of a trillion years then very few
if any would appear before today
then a couple more arrive in this period
of a billion years that we're in before
all starfaring civilizations that could
ever exist emerge altogether
this weird tsunami-like distribution is
the result of both the hard steps model
and something else
a sort of deadline for any space-faring
civilization
any civilization coming after will find
it hard to have room to survive so all
potential life has to cram in before it
Humanity exists now because otherwise we
might have missed this deadline what or
who creates this deadline
why aren't aliens already on Earth
humans are curious expansionist and
hungry for energy
we've spread over the world and made it
our own our technology has been
improving over time first slowly then
breathtakingly fast
if these things don't change drastically
and our descendants want to prosper they
will expand into space
we could construct a Dyson swarm for
Endless energy and transform planets
into new homes we could cross
Interstellar distances allowing us to
reach for planets around distant Stars
if we have the motivation we can become
a Galactic Civilization
a civilization that does this sort of
stuff can be called Loud because its
activity creates noise signs that can be
detected from far away imagine someone
in a forest cutting down trees starting
fires and laying down roads the more
intense their work the easier they are
to notice an expanding technological
civilization would probably be hard to
miss our telescopes would pick up all
that energy and we would clearly
identify artificial interference with
stars and planets
another consequence of this business is
that it's very disruptive to the
environment
clearing a forest means the end of its
Wildlife human activity has left no
chance for a squirrel civilization to
appear
not because we hated squirrels it's
something that the thought that they
might want to do that at some point
never crossed our minds and we needed
wood
similarly if loud civilizations were
running around the galaxy in the past
terraforming planets or harvesting the
energy of stars they may have prevented
our existence had aliens started
colonizing Earth while we were still
sludging the oceans that sludge would
never have turned into humans
this is how loud aliens create a
deadline for new civilizations appearing
the Galaxy may have trillions of years
to create life but there may only be a
short window for it to spread and thrive
even if a loud civilization respects
planets with naturally occurring life
and expands around them like humans do
with Wildlife reserves any civilization
on such a planet would not be able to
expand ever
trapped Forever on a tiny Island
but here we are so loud aliens will
probably never hear
what about aliens that don't expand they
would be quiet aliens they're probably
limited to one star system and don't
have a noticeable impact on their Cosmic
surroundings humanity is like this right
now we wouldn't be able to detect
ourselves from the other side of the
Milky Way
if they stay quiet forever maybe because
of their culture or abilities then they
are not really a concern for us
we only have one sample to draw from
humanity and right now we are on the
path to becoming loud
if we're not special lands succeed
anyway then any other civilization with
the motivation and resources to would
eventually expand Beyond its planet of
origin
okay what are the consequences of all
these assumptions and ideas
[Music]
grave consequences race to the Stars
if we are really early then eventually
others will catch up with us
civilizations will emerge all over the
place and these new aliens will look at
space see no signs of life and come to
the same conclusion they exist because
loud civilizations have not yet taken
over everything but it only takes one
loud civilization to crowd them out of
the entire galaxy
they like us will face an important
decision do they stay quiet take it easy
and turn to their planet for as long as
possible or do they start expanding to
take a chunk of the Galaxy before
someone else arrives
meeting others does not necessarily mean
War or conflict but it means that new
borders will arise limits that may
persist forever
in the worst case a civilization could
be completely enveloped by the empires
of others
eternally doomed to be a galactic
Backwater without control over their
fate
so if we want a seat at the galactic
adults table we best get to work if we
really are early we have an incredible
opportunity to mold thousands or even
millions of planets according to our
vision and dreams
and one day when we meet others we can
greet them and meet them as equals
wouldn't that be nice
if you want to explore the vast Universe
from the comfort of your own home we've
got a lot of amazing Space and Science
inspired products for you all of our
products are designed and produced with
love and care by us here at kotskazakhs
they're an integral part of the science
story we try to tell so start your
journey on our Channel and continue it
with one of our posters notebooks or
plushes every purchase directly funds
what we do on this channel
thank you so much for your support and
never stop dreaming of Space Adventures
[Music]